okay so what i'm here to talk about yes
you notice the headlamp on
on my head and uh i'll be doing some
live theater here so this is kind of the
demos could go well or they could go
completely terribly uh and we'll find
out i guess
um so i'm coming with some very exciting
news
in this wonderful year 2020 the era of
the internet
the year of linux on the desktop it's so
much easier to screw up
than it has ever been before you can
screw up in
so many more ways than you ever thought
were possible and you can make
even bigger screw-ups too this is really
good news
um no i'm serious this is really good
news
and over the next 10 minutes i'm going
to tell you about one of my new favorite
ways
to screw up but before we get there
we make tiny scripts that we learn from
every single day and
it's important that we have the space to
do it screwing up is how we learn or
phrased a different way you can't learn
without space to screw up
uh for work recently i was learning rust
maybe for
the first time or maybe for the third
time depends on who you ask
um and i was just immensely grateful for
a compiler that taught me how to screw
up let me just bring up a little window
here and i'm going to
open up some rust here uh let's see if
we can test my knowledge here function
main
is print line i'd like to just print two
plus two here
easy enough rust c main.rs
and the compiler tells me that i've
screwed up and the compiler helpfully
gives me this hint here and says okay uh
in order to not do that
why don't you invoke print line as if it
were a macro okay i'll do that
and it tells me okay i've screwed up one
more time here
and it tells me so the compiler is
telling me that i've screwed up and has
given me space to screw up and rather
than crashing the computer or something
else
it it instructs me how to not do that
um so you can't learn without space to
screw up
and i want to tell briefly to put a
little bit of context here about a time
when i couldn't screw up in 2005 it was
really really expensive to screw up
hardware
i was a kid i was in high school i knew
i was interested in electronics and
hardware and all that kind of stuff and
it was so expensive
i would go to radio shack and i'd get
these like 10 resistor kits
and if i wanted to get integrated
circuits if radio shack had the one that
i wanted
they were like three bucks a shot and so
if i blew that up three bucks right
there right
um and if i wanted to get something
radio shack didn't have i'd have to go
online and order it
i'd go to digikey and ups shipping was
like 20 bucks and it would take like a
week and a half for my digikey
man it was bad and like if i wanted to
fab out a pcb
back in 2005 the cheapest that i could
do was advanced circuits so that was
for pcb you might remember uh if you
were
thinking about those kinds of things
back then and they had their their 33
each special which wasn't 33
each because you had to order three of
them so that was a hundred bucks and for
your
100 bucks you got three copies of a
two-layer no solder mask board
in two thousand five dollars so in
twenty twenty dollars that's 130 bucks
anyway so like
what what would you do you know your kid
interested in electronics out would come
the
laser jet that you got from the town
dump and i'd run inkjet photo paper
through it and
i'd iron it on and get out the nasty
etchant chemicals and
since i didn't have a soldering station
you know i had this kind of well weller
fire starter
station i sold her surface mount parts
and my mom's toaster went hi mom happy
mother's day
um and the results were bad like i would
end up with like very crispy boards
so i didn't make a whole lot of boards
and my skills consequently never really
got very good
if if you can think about it like you
could imagine that instead of having a
compiler that a second
later gave you an error that told you it
was wrong it was a compiler that took a
whole
evening of work and nasty chemicals and
didn't really tell you it was wrong just
had a bunch of things shorted together
and uh and you blow up your board
so i'm here to tell you that
in 2020 screwing up hardware is cheap
and fast
over the past couple of years there's
been almost an explosion of extremely
low-cost pcb vendors
in the u.s we have ash park i think
they're based out of oregon
um and so there let's see three copies
for five bucks a square inch
um and it ships in 9 to 12 days
so okay sure pcb way
in shenzhen that's even faster and jlc
pcv okay here you go
pcb plus surface mount assembly from two
bucks
you can get anything in shenzhen
all right and so this whole thing i i
didn't really believe it i i ordered
some circuit boards i designed a board
um i'll hold it up to the camera in a
moment here i designed a board
and i designed it in key cad totally
open source software here there i got
them a week later i'm just uh you got me
here just in time to put the finishing
touches on soldering it here
so let me show you i've got
my little usb microscope here i've got a
soldering iron and all i've got to do
is i've got to get this voltage
regulator
right on here you can see that it heats
up
while i'm doing that let's just add a
little more solder here
come here
and you'll see that as soon as the part
heats up as soon as it wicks you get
this little sucking effect where the pad
or where the part just lines itself
right up on the pad there
right the reason why i'm wearing this
headlamp is i can get a little extra
light on here to help with these little
tiny surface mount components
come here one of those
one of those and one of those
all right all right perfect done deal
and the most exciting thing i think the
most exciting thing about a board
bring up is about getting boards back is
the first time you get powered on so i
have my little bench power supply here
you don't need a bench power supply to
do electronics these days you can get
away with with just so much less
connect to that like that gave myself
two nice little pins there
ah the most exciting thing is powering
up for the first time
oh man that just went up in smoke real
good uh that's
that's not great that smells really bad
oh man ha gotcha gotcha i thought i
thought
you thought i wasn't expecting that i
made this totally classic mistake
i signed the pins on the voltage
regulator wrong it happens all the time
it just happened on a board that i
brought up for one of my clients like
the experts the pros did this
and so like this kind of thing it's so
it's so common and this is the kind of
thing you couldn't do before
and so okay here we go another week
let's say i just fabbed out the um
the replacement for this and another 10
bucks later
let's just go right back over to the
cameras here
put this one right under my microscope
find that there
and so like previously this would have
been the end of it right i wouldn't have
done another i wouldn't have done
another version of this board
because it's so expensive and it's so
it's just so
agonizing when things go wrong like this
um
oh chasing it under the microscope
it's just so agonizing when these kinds
of things go wrong
and you know that's it's just miserable
right
um and so
now that you know now that this didn't
cost me you know everything that i'd
earned in a week kind of thing or
whatever it was
it was it's a much different story so
hang on so let's let's power this on
this time
um power this put that there
get one of those there give myself
plenty of power and
ooh more smoke boy that smells really
bad oh god tantalum cap smoke
okay so so again
you can just keep you can just keep
making mistakes this is the amazing
thing that i just love about this
process now
that just totally wasn't possible what
happened there i don't know if you
noticed
is um on electrolytic caps the
on electrolytic capacitors one specific
type of capacitor
the little line uh you can see it'll
point to it this little line on the end
of the cap
marks negative but on tantalum
capacitors
it marks positive and this is one of
those things that yes you could learn
you could read the data sheet and you
could learn that and all that kind of
stuff
um and you could let's see if i can pick
up another one and just place
the replacement there my hands might be
too shaky and this board might get away
without it
yeah i think this board will be fine
with that well let's see if this one
let's see if this one works huh
um
the this is one of those things that you
can learn either
by reading wikipedia and reading the
data sheets hey look at that it's
blinking
all right um you can learn it that way
or you can learn it the hard way and the
hard way is kind of the more fun way
sometimes
that's kind of my claim so
in 2005 this whole thing would have cost
me 200 bucks
and it would have cost me two months and
that's just for the boards okay and so
for the parts it would have been another
30 bucks in parts
or 20 bucks in ups shipping and really
what that would have meant is i would
have given up before i even tried
and so the amazing thing is here in 2020
i ordered boards on a saturday evening
and they arrived
on a thursday evening from shenzhen
and the whole thing cost me 20 bucks i
actually ordered both rounds because
as you may have noticed that was a
planned screw-up right
um but okay so that whole thing for 10
boards 10 totally custom boards two
different designs in there
um the whole thing ran me 20 bucks
shipped and then the parts
ran me about 30 bucks shipped i ordered
those on saturday evening they arrived
tuesday evening
and you can do this at home i used a
hand-me-down soldering station from a
former housemate and a hand-me-down
power supply
you can get soldering stations for
really cheap these days if you're
daring you could cut open a usb cable
and get you some 5 volt power this
microscope
was 25 bucks off amazon why wait
okay what do i actually have to tell you
here
um make mistakes
[Music]
it's so important to make mistakes
and when you're making mistakes that
could be in the compiler
it could be when you're actually
physically assembling things
you might tear something apart and rip a
cable and while you're trying to fix it
it happens all the time you can't learn
without it
blow some stuff up right don't get
conservative in your designs because
you're worried about
not letting out the magic smoke let out
as much magic smoke as you can it's lots
of fun
it smells a little bit bad um and
the overarching thing here is that it's
important to feel safe screwing up it's
important that you feel
kind of financially safe in screwing up
that means that it's a
20 buck disaster rather than a hundred
dollar disaster
it's important with your compiler to not
crash your machine and so when rusty
complains about the borrow checker and
this and that and the other thing
um it's important to feel safe that
you're not going to like
overwrite your root file system and so
having those guards helps us
experiment and in human spaces it's
important to feel safe screwing up also
i feel like i love the bang bang khan
aesthetic of we have the hard rules of
things not to do but we have these
social rules of
the well actually is that somebody can
come up to you and say you just well
actually them and you go like oh man
thanks for telling me and
you feel safe making a mistake because
you know you can learn
whether you're using rust c or whether
you're in a soldering iron or
in a in a real live space or a virtual
space together there's never been a
better time to screw up
uh thank you to all of you stuck around
to the end to watch and
thanks to the bang bang con organizers
this year who gave us a joyful delight
to the full
and surprising conference despite all of
us sitting around sheltered in place